who was uh like the first push a Inc
like was it Ty or was it YG who was kind
of the the founding three members is Ace
Obama y g PC okay and then Tai became a
part of it yeah later on Big B rest in
peace Big B Big B brought in Tai and he
brought in mustard oh [__] is it true
Mustard's first beat ever was p cake
yeah bro he told me that was the first
beat he ever made no cap like mustard
didn't used to produce he was a DJ but
bro for a long time and this is before I
was an anr like why you he mustard was
so tired of everybody sending them the
same beat over and over over and over
it's like everybody was trying to put
him into a certain box or certain type
of Style music and they were trying to
figure out how to get out of it so
mustard ducked off paid attention for a
while him and Mike free created the
sound like Mike free actually taught
mustard how to produce right people
don't know that yeah Mike free is a very
underrated guy in La man shout out Mike
free man for sure but yeah no um and
then mustard just took what Mike free
gave him and just enhanced that to the
next level cuz he he understood it from
a different realm like you're a DJ you
know like no you you know what to what
what to make to make people D exactly
and what you looking for for a certain
type of hour in that party and it's like
I feel like that's where a lot of
producers are slacking now for sure cuz
they're like just stuck in the house
playing fortnite jerking off and making
beats they go around no energy no
nothing they just making on a computer
watching porn but it's like she ain't
really in your face shaking ass how you
feel
it damn um so obviously uh for you
you've turned being a professional homie
into being at anr at inter scope for cup
of te inter scope for about I was at
inter scope for about 8 years years
while I was there I signed people like
money bag yo Rich the kid um Aaron Ray
did drez's first album Mitch D's hard
super slept on man it was her first out
Mitch shout out to Mitch that's my guy
that's my a homie man bro Mitch out here
killing it Mitch is incredible and every
time I see his Instagram it makes me
feel really bad about my my body man
Mitch just had a baby shout out
to Mitch man shout out to Mitch Mitch is
a real one very slept on artist he
what's it the red tape the [__] he has
on I know oh my God yeah hey that's like
lowkey like might be like my second
favorite YG album that's on Spotify
that's fire the red tape is so good red
tape was just a Vibe it was fun it
wasn't it was no bars no like he was
just having fun with music that [__] was
hard shout out to uh to to the homie Jay
waves too be over there with Mitch man
repping a man shout out to those guys um
so yeah so so when you say because a lot
of people don't understand what anr does
and when they say well you signed
somebody to the label give us like a
like what does that mean exactly so like
um you you look for talent you search
and you find Talent then you try to
bring that talent to the label and then
you try to help that artist who already
had some going get to that next level or
understand themsel more understand like
what's the message that they trying to
feed off to the world like and it's so
[__] up cuz I feel like it's not a lot
of real anrs no more because everybody
want to sign somebody that's already on
that's already based off analytics
versus you going to find an artist you
believe in or you finding somebody when
it's first starting like oh I can see
the trajectory or where that can go like
for me is I've never signed an artist
who would had like a crazy ass deal
where every lady was fighting for him I
fought for the artist who I personally
believed in yeah it's like whoever the
an anr is at uh I won't even say never
mind bad example well not a bad example
but I won't say but yes you're right
like hey congratulations you signed that
tick tocker yeah or just like you know
[__] if you sign sexy red congrats
she's the hottest [__] alive man shout
out gamma shout out to gamma gamma's
[__] they got Usher and they got Rick
Ross listen and they got French Montana
listen Jackson he
knows putting it together over there
respect to everything he's doing at game
100% man I sexy red I didn't that see
that was a bad example but yeah like
yeah sign sexy red of course you know
why you got a new single dropping with
sexy red real soon stay I saw they shot
the video how was it having a pregnant
sexy red in the hood over there bro that
[__] was honestly bro I ain't been a
bomp in a minute like with with the
pregnant hottest chick on the planet
yeah and it was like [__] we was over
there we pulled up first I got sent a
address I get sent the ad pull up to
this house ain't nobody there I'm like
what the [__] is going on calling
everybody then like [__] we in the
alley [__] go to the alley [__] all you
see is [__] red everywhere oh wow oh
all right I'm comfortable now all right
where the homies at but it was cool it
was a dope video um the home girl minie
she's from La she does um sexy red
styling and [__] so shout out to her um
sexy red came through and it's crazy cuz
she's still humble and you appreciate
that like people get to normal as [__]
exactly gang I [__] with it she put up
in Crocs no back Crocs she like [__]
y'all got my y'all showing my feet well
if y'all ain't showing my feet I ain't
putting these heels on I said you got it
yeah now she came and did my club in
Crocs last week oh God like I I [__] I
[__] with her energy like a lot of
people say a lot of things um I respect
anything that's au's authentic as [__]
ex you feel me like that's like if
that's she's unapologetically herself
exactly and that's five it's not an
image or nothing it's like at all she
just that's who she is like you [__]
with it you [__] with it you don't she
don't give a [__] that's why she's
winning I wish more people would like
that 100%